مشاركه نواسعه للقاده العرب في قمتين
اثنتين تستضيفهم السعوديه واحده خليجيه
صينيه والثانيه عربيه صينيه
القمه اللتان تشهدان حضور الرئيس الصيني
شجنبيج تاتيا عقب قمه صينيه سعوديه اتفقت
فيها كل من السعوديه والصين على عده نقاط
اهمها تعزيز التعاون في مجال الاستخدامات
السلميه للطاقه النوويه التاكيد على
الالتزام بمبدا الصين الواحده زياده حجم
التبادل التجاري غير النفطيه اهميه الحل
السلمي للصراعي في اوكرانيا وضروره
استقرار اسواق نفطر العالميه
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه في تحقيق
التقدم والتنميه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه
الشامله
وقبل القمه العربيه الصينيه التقى الرئيس
الصيني بالرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
وبالرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
فيما تراقب الولايات المتحده بقلق تنام
النفوذ الصينيين في الشرق الاوسط وواسط
تدهور لعلاقاتها مع الرياض